produire et vendre son foie gras ils en
rêvaient depuis longtemps il y a 6 ans
vincent caillou a repris l'élevage de
canards de la fauconnière au coeur de la
sologne
donc là on est dans une postière donc là
vous avez des canetons qui ont huit
jours donc ils vont rester pendant trois
semaines ici avec un chauffage éclairage
en permanence et sont nourris avec un
mélange de céréales et de poudre de lait
ici on élève près de 2500 canard à
l'année des mulard croisement entre le
canard de barbarie et la canne de pékin
comme dans le cochon dans le canard tout
est bon mais la technique de gavage qui
permet d'obtenir le foie gras concentre
les critiques des défenseurs des animaux
les canards non les élèves tous semaine
et ils sont gavés à raison de deux
minutes dans leur vie donc si vous
laissez pas grand chose et ce qui est
important c'est tout le bien-être de
l'élevage les animaux plus vous les
confiner plus vous allez développer des
maladies donc le fait de travailler sur
un système plein air bien on respecte ou
le bien-être le bien-être animal
face au mouvement anti viande en général
le producteur se défend c'est un petit
peu des ayatollahs donc non moi je dis
que les gens qui veulent pas manger de
viande
c'est un choix ça moi je suis pas je
suis pas contre mais qu'on laisse la
liberté à chacun d'eux de consommer
comme comme il a envie aujourd'hui
l'exploitation emploie cinq salariés la
découpe se fait sur place isoler le foie
gras demande une certaine expérience et
beaucoup de précautions me laisse
reposer quand même
24 heures et puis après on va le dvd
c'est à dire qu'on va retirer
l'événement qui se situe là qui sont à
l'intérieur du foie on enlève aussi la
tâche de fiel continuant la puis après
vente prestataire pour vendre les foies
gras en cette période de crise sanitaire
la ferme de l'afo bonnière mise sur son
réseau de clients particuliers
un site internet a été développé pour
l'occasion et ceux qui le souhaitent
peuvent toujours se rendre sur place à
la boutique je connais pas ça va être
l'écouté ça va être la première fois je
vais manger du foie gras de sologne
et puis on veut favoriser si vous voulez
le circuit court voilà c'est ce qui pour
nous est très un très important pour
l'instant les ventes démarrent doucement
mais le producteur espère que la
solidarité locale jouera aussi pour les
fêtes de fin d'année